Trascrizione: Martina Margoni
Revisore: Alessandro Lai
Buon pomeriggio a tutti!
Quello che vedete alle mie spalle è un rendering,
è il rendering del nostro appartamento, mio e del mio ragazzo, Daniele.
E' un appartamento che abbiamo acquistato qualche mese fa, a Trento, in città
e abbiamo pensato di ristrutturare, e ci siamo chiesti come ristrutturarlo.
Volevamo fare qualcosa che fosse particolare,
che fosse unico, che si intersecasse con le nostre vite,
col nostro modo di essere, di pensare.
E come concretizzare quest'idea?
Abbiamo incontrato un'azienda, un'azienda italiana che si occupa di arredamento e di design.
In realtà, perché io mi occupo di diritto d'autore, di proprietà intellettuale e di accesso alla conoscenza,
questo è stato il canale attraverso il quale siamo venuti in contatto con questa azienda
e ci siamo conosciuti reciprocamente.
All'esito di questo percorso, abbiamo deciso di intraprendere un progetto,
che è quello di cui vi sto per parlare, che vedrà come protagonista noi, come persone
ed il nostro appartamento, quale canale di condivisione e di cultura.
Il nostro appartamento, infatti, vorremmo che diventasse, non solo un luogo di vita privata,
ma anche un luogo aperto, aperto alle altre persone, alle persone esterne.
Quindi vogliamo rompere un po' con quello che è lo schema tradizionale
con cui siamo abituati a confrontarci.
Vorremmo che, nel nostro appartamento, potessimo organizzare degli eventi,
che si potesse trasformare la casa in una galleria d'arte
per ospitare un giovane artista che voglia farsi conoscere,
in una sala da concerti per consentire di esibirsi ad un giovane musicista.
Oppure, perché no, anche un temporary store.
Può sembrare un'idea folle, forse utopica?
Invece, in realtà, non è poi così folle né così utopica.
Ci sono già delle realtà in cui questo progetto si è concretizzato con successo.
In una realtà molto vicina alla nostra, a Bolzano, a Milano.
Io e Daniele abbiamo visto queste realtà
e ci siamo convinti ancora di più di seguire ed intraprendere questo percorso.
Al centro, naturalmente, c'è l'idea di un design modulare,
che consenta, quindi, di trasformare la casa come fosse un giocattolo;
da un luogo appunto intimo, dedicato alla famiglia,
ad un luogo, invece, aperto al pubblico, alla comunità.
Noi pensiamo che, questo progetto, sia anche un progetto di vita.
Un progetto che può, nel nostro piccolo, andare verso un cambiamento sociale.
Può migliorare la nostra vita, la qualità della nostra vita
e la qualità della vita delle persone che stanno accanto a noi,
delle nostre famiglie, dei nostri amici ma anche della nostra comunità.
Perché consentiamo di venire alle persone, di vivere la vita ...
anche una vita relazionale del nostro appartamento,
di partecipare agli eventi; quasi un ritorno a quello forse che, era una volta, il "filò".
Non so se ve lo ricordate, che si faceva nelle case dei nostri nonni probabilmente.
Oggi abbiamo perso questa dimensione di condivisione,
di relazione, di apprezzare, anche, lo stare con gli altri, di condividere le esperienze,
siamo tutti un po' individualisti.
Questo secondo noi, è un piccolo passaggio, che attraverso questo canale,
che in questo caso è appunto l'appartamento, cerchiamo di perseguire.
Vorrei terminare questa mia testimonianza,
perché di fatto è una testimonianza che va nella direzione del cambiamento,
accoglie le sfide che oggi, un po' tutti i relatori ci hanno lanciato.
E vorrei terminare questa mia brevissima testimonianza,
con un pensiero che Steve Jobs ha lanciato ai giovani laureati di Stanford,
invitandoli ad essere "folli", a seguire le proprie aspirazioni,
anche se queste possono sembrare irrealizzabili, oppure utopiche.
Perché solo questo è quello che ci consente di evolvere, è un motore per il miglioramento.
Chiudo, dunque, con le parole di Steve Jobs:
"Il vostro tempo è limitato,
quindi non sprecatelo vivendo la vita di qualcun'altro, siate affamati, siate folli!".
Grazie.